it's kind of scary when you realize how
much damage is can be brought to the
World by one single person this guy
pulled a massive trick on so many people
and the financial damages are in the
billions with the B from one person's
Behavior think of how scary that is
Spencer Cornelia welcome to the show I'd
love to be here right now this is an
interesting moment and I am super
excited for this conversation yes I I
feel like it would have been nice for
our first conversation to have been
under less insane situation but uh yeah
man it's it's a very very important time
has it ever been this crazy do you think
in the finance space
never but this is what leads to the most
enjoyable conversations right yeah yeah
nothing's going on there's nothing to
talk about well I think the internet's
completely washed with conversations
about the downfall of FTX which was a
crypto trading platform and Sam bankman
freed who was the owner CEO and where he
is and what he's doing and stuff I don't
think that we need to do a huge
post-mortem on that I think that's
already kind of been done by people what
I'm interested in is having a
conversation about the ethics of the
influences that was promoting that
platform and then also what this means
for moving forward the effective
altruism movement which some Magnum
freed was hugely influential and
involved in he was the single biggest
donor toward that and then kind of some
uh speculation about what he and the
crypto world might do next because
that's those are the most interesting
things I think but we do need to start
with some kind of a primer so if
somebody has been underground for the
last five days week or so how would you
explain what has happened in the crypto
world over the last week
someone who went on a trip to Europe
might have completely missed the entire
story you know how crazy that's how fast
it was uh so essentially there was a
tweet that really kicked off a bank run
essentially there was a tweet by a
competitor
that was signifying that there might be
issues at their number one competitor it
kicks off a bank run and within 24 hours
the second biggest Exchange in the
crypto Market is bankrupt how insane
so essentially it kicked off a
collateral damage Firestorm and what's
so fascinating about this case is you
have a lot of people involved you have
real influencers with global audiences
NFL players NBA players you also have
influencers in the YouTube space and
this is to my knowledge just off top of
my head this might be the first time
we've really seen something go awry that
includes both Global celebrities and
influencers YouTubers more specifically
and they're all kind of guilty of the
same thing and it's fascinating to see
The Fallout
what do you mean when you say Bank Run
a bank run for this example is
essentially there might not be money
left in this in this company they're
insolvent and so they're supposed to be
holding customer deposits and so if you
hear that a bank a crypto exchange
whatever that's supposed to be holding
your money might be insolvent what's the
first thing a reasonable person would do
you go on your app and you say give me
my money back and when that happens to
the extent of six billion dollars as
reported within 24 hours if you only
have let's say a billion dollars in
assets and all of a sudden six billion
dollars worth of money is being asked
for you don't have the money to pay
everyone out and then when people aren't
able to get their money pandemonium
comes in and with social media news
stories spreads like wildfire once it's
reported that your money might be gone
pandemonium sets in and I think that's
what we saw
should it be the case that a crypto
exchange is using uses capital for
anything other than simply holding it on
their books ready for them to withdraw I
know that that's what banks do is that
common practice or should that be common
practice for crypto exchanges well
absolutely because it's not their money
right when you take on money you should
just get a cut of the of the fees the
small fees that's how you make your
money yeah what's so dangerous about
this is you have someone who
took customer money and essentially went
and gambled it away on a something
that's even more risky which is these
crypto tokens what are they worth I
don't know for me in my eyes I don't
think they're worth anything but there's
a community that thinks thinks they're
worth something well unfortunately when
that crypto token goes to nothing and
that you're borrowing money against that
token you're leveraging trading it it
creates a essentially a Ponzi scheme and
yeah it's really unfortunate because you
have one person that acted totally
against the terms of service of his own
company and it created a uh essentially
a Ponzi scheme and unfortunately Ponzi
schemes is they fall immediately and it
happens within 24 hours
that's sandbagman freed CEO and owner
founder of uh FTX and of Alameda
research that are the two big companies
that are involved in that can you just
explain what's going on and how all of
those client funds ended up going
somewhere that they weren't supposed to
I'd love to know where the money went
that's always the first question
so he was he's the owner of Alameda
research which is a trading firm and
then he's also owns FTX and now we're
finding out that he was the owner of 3
000 different llc's it feels like where
did the money go because he was buying
real estate apparently right before
which by the way is uh usually an
indication that they know they're at
fault is right before the hammer comes
down they're always buying stuff they
somehow magically have money they're
buying 200 million dollars worth I think
there's reports out there who knows
what's true but a lot of these guys go
out and buy a bunch of assets that you
might not be able to find
and uh yeah it's really unfortunate I
I'm guessing the money went in his
pocket
oh sorry we also know we also yeah
bankman freed we also know that he was
the second biggest political donor in
the Democratic party so there's like
layers to this story that might come out
in the next week we might find out this
goes way deeper than just one bad actor
this could be a systemic issue
why was it that that business was
operated out of and registered in the
Bahamas is there some
extra degrees of [ __ ] that you're
allowed to do if you're over there
it's a great question I'm not entirely
sure my guess is yes when you're
unregulated and that that brings into
question you know about the the
companies that you get behind or you
invest in or you put your money in if
they're overseas it adds a extra layer
of risk I think
I don't really know my get my guess is
because they weren't in the US they're
not regulated and so they can get away
with what they're doing okay yes so
should this have all been foreseen
was this foreseeable this this a huge
downfall was is it right to say that the
smart people were able to see this
coming from a Million Miles Away
if you ask YouTube right now everyone
saw it coming but my guess is no look
there's companies that put 200 million
dollars into this business you have
Venture Capital numerous Venture
capitalists you have people that looked
at their books that didn't know of
course you know what what's unfortunate
about situations like this is the the
follow-up what happens immediately after
is the next week everyone becomes a
forensic researcher and then they find
one interview one article one incident
and they go oh my God how did we not see
this coming
the challenge it's always 20 20. like
there's so many things out there that
look Shady that are totally legit uh
unfortunately when something bad happens
everyone looks to you know how do we not
see this and then it becomes quote
unquote obvious after the fact so good
question depending on who you ask some
people think they could have seen this
coming
seem to fool everyone why didn't they
contact the SEC right if everyone knew
it was a scam why didn't you contact the
SEC you could have saved a lot of people
money right if you want to play the
moral game do we not see this with
SoftBank and uh wework as well right
that they were supposed to be this
hugely successful they can do the
forensic accounts they put this money
into a company that claims it's a tech
company and it's it's not a tech company
it's a real estate company masquerading
as a tech company but because they had a
seductive CEO
everybody was prepared to not observe
perhaps some of the elephants that were
in the room uh but yeah I mean I I don't
know it does strike me as strange that
no one saw this coming if in retrospect
it was so obvious
oh yeah I'm being a little facetious
here
um because some people right now are
making videos about how obvious it all
was and I think that's a little
disingenuous like it's good to have
skepticism and raise concerns by all
means and if you're right bump your
chest you're right however I'm just
saying that
um there's a lot of things that seem
Shady or seem like they're X Y and Z and
it's only until it comes out that it is
that then those people are right right
but they weren't were they going to The
Regulators were they going to the SEC
right were they emailing people just
saying like hey you should look into
this a little more
I don't know I I would have never seen
it coming as did you know massive
investors that put hundreds of millions
of dollars in this company what about
Enron was a public company right the
stuff just happens unfortunately very
unfortunate and people lose money but uh
yeah now you're now we're in that news
cycle of
let's figure out
where did we go wrong yeah there's video
clips of maybe the CEO or something
talking about how she only uses uh
Primary School level mathematics at
hijab even though she's got a PhD and
sunbankment freed basically admitting to
the fact that it's a large Ponzi scheme
and at the time that looks like uh
cutesy
uh casual language in retrospect that
looks like a Smoking Gun and absolutely
yeah I think that it it is an
interesting one to consider why people
put so much faith into sandbankment
freed as somebody that I'd heard I am
not in the crypto space I am not a part
of the investing world or the finance
World I'd heard through personal friends
about some of the dodgy [ __ ] that he was
doing that he had access a backdoor into
the uh trades on the back end of FTX and
he was able to short to like uh get in
ahead of short positions and long
positions on different trades in order
to scalp extra money off the top four
either himself or for FTX so I mean
again but like what am I going to do am
I am I does that mean that I'm going to
ignore this huge what is the second
largest third largest crypto Exchange in
the world like it's only fortunate that
I have the tiny sliver like two Grands
worth of bitcoin that I own is on
coinbase like for all had I have gone on
a different app on a different day it
would have been FTX and that would have
been my money on as well
yeah and that brings up an interesting
question which is is promoting coinbase
right now is it scammy
should you get FL you know did anyone
who promoted crypto.com coinbase they're
all kind of the same right if you if you
think the system is all a scam right in
regards to these exchanges then you'd
say it's unethical it's just what's
challenging is you don't you don't
really know until it happens right
everyone's a genius after the fact and
unfortunately we'll have that new cycle
now my guess is there's probably gonna
be another week of this and then people
will come to their senses and we'll
start to dig in thankfully what
generally happens too is you you have a
group of people that realize like
something bad happened how can we how
can we protect ourselves from this in
the future and then that's when we start
look at the signs and we go okay well
let's start looking around in other
places and try to figure out
where who else is going wrong truly
though there's some rightful retribution
and Vengeance and Ayah that needs to be
directed at all of the people that ran
that company like it's not just about
like oh okay let's just let whatever 10
billion dollars worth of capital go and
then we'll you know we'll just move on
we'll learn from it and continue going
forward that's not the way it works
right I agree yeah unfortunately in
situations like this really everyone's
to blame everyone who's involved right
you Influence People you put your name
to it that's just part of the game if
you sponsor something you're gonna
you're gonna face reputational damage if
things go wrong that's unfortunately
part of the risk you take on with with
taking on money have you been doing any
research about what the CEO sandbankment
freed is doing right now it seems like
people are trying to track different
Jets and stuff out of the Bahamas and
he's going to Argentina or maybe Dubai
or something with no extradition I don't
know
yeah crypto Twitter right now is
certainly an interesting place I feel
like it's the it's drama for adults like
we we look at um we look at certain
shows on TV like the Kardashians and ink
guys we're like wow I would never watch
that stuff but then like we we tune into
the most drama full
space on the internet which is crypto
Twitter you know when stuff like this is
happening it is our version of drama
I I don't know what he's doing I don't
think anyone knows what he's doing
there's a lot of speculation it is
pretty fascinating though once someone
gets caught
what are they doing they're always
running apparently it seems like he's
got maybe between half a billion and a
billion of
um publicly known cash still left over
so you basically got unlimited funds to
be able to find people to squirrel you
away to travel and be secure provide
security and close protection and [ __ ]
like that for you uh but I would guess
that there will be a lot of people very
very keen to try and find out where he
is but I don't really know what you do
what do you do if you get your hands on
sandbankment freed
he's next to you going to the bathroom
hey wait you're you're the most hated
man in the world right now what do you
do well I mean
what
what are the legalities are you aware of
the legalities of what has been done
no right no not at all obviously there's
gonna be criminal proceedings but I have
no idea to me it just seems you just you
just go find him okay here's the thing
we can track people down if they can't
make a car payment right in Las Vegas
Nevada here if someone doesn't make a
car payment somehow some Dog the Bounty
Hunter is able to find him within 24
hours you're telling me we don't have
the ability to find a guy worth a
billion dollars that says public as him
I just don't buy it and so I I'm just
shocked that this stuff they don't have
a full team of us full SWAT team outside
his house or wherever he is right can
you not track his phone
but if he's across multiple different
countries and jurisdictions who do you
send do you send to the American
government send someone to Dubai
that's fair I guess that's the benefit
of being in the Bahamas he was in the
Bahamas so then yeah there's reports who
knows what's true there's reports of him
like paying off the local police
so that yeah then that comes into
question if someone's making the
equivalent of 30 000 US dollars a year
if someone paid them a million dollars
to just say don't show up or show up to
my house and say I'm not here
I'm not saying that's the ethical thing
to do but I I get it right right that
was one of the reasons that uh John
McCarthy decided to stay in the where
was he not Venezuela
he was in I remember he was in some
insane El Salvador I believe or
something like that and uh one of the
big reasons was that corruption was
going to be much more uh easy for him to
complete and if you've got someone that
can backhand all of the local
prosecutors and police Chiefs
you've got a lot less to worry about so
there's a Kanye West song where it goes
there's no one man should have all this
power it's kind of scary when you
realize how much damages can be brought
to the World by one single person
this guy pulled a massive trick on so
many people
and the financial damages are in the
billions with the B
from one person's Behavior think of how
scary that is
and there were there were there's a
system in place to try and prevent this
to some degree right you have people
investing their money obviously they're
going to try they're going to do their
best to make sure their money's safe in
regards to the investors and people
close to him you even had employees at
his company that I'm sure were the were
are great people that had no idea and
they were able to get fooled
scary isn't it
I didn't know man I mean
I wonder what sort of pressures have
been placed on him behind the scenes I
think the guy is ultimately the uh
bearer of responsibility that's what the
CEO and founder owner's job is
um but there's no way that it's only him
that was involved in right you know this
conversation my favorite conspiracy is
that SBF was a government Insider who's
trying to give the government a good
justification to more heavily scrutinize
the crypto industry by purposefully
bringing it down
that would be an amazing movie plot
coming to you in 2025.
if that's true man that is even more
scary I think because there's an
inherent level of trust we have and a
lot of people in government regardless
of if you you know like government or
not I think there is an inherent trust
like they're going to go after the bad
guys and if you find out they were in
bed with the bad guys and in some sense
giving them more power
who's to say someone else out there
isn't as corrupt well especially given
that the crypto Community is very
anti-authority very anti-government it
doesn't want oversight the entire reason
for having a decentralized currency is
that you're safe and secure and walled
off from all of this stuff and yeah I
think this is one of the reasons that uh
well I learned about you're glowing have
you heard about glowing on the internet
oh yeah so it's uh I think it's a term
that people use to identify someone that
they think is potentially a federal
agent or a government Insider that is
trying to move the conversation in a
particular direction and you're glowing
is we can see that you're actually not
one of us you're one of these Bad actors
that's in here to try and infiltrate and
get us to do stuff or say stuff that
we're not supposed to
huh not familiar well I haven't learned
something new every day
what about stuff like coinbase then
would you be worried about coinbase
from the standpoint of it falling I
think there's going to be a massive
Fallout because my sense of crypto and
by the way I'm I'm pretty ignorant to
all this but you know I know enough to
at least when I see the Twitter crypto
Twitter talk about this that there's
going to be massive follow-up meaning
there a lot of these companies seem to
be interconnected to some degree there's
loans and there's leverage and once you
have one company fall if they were if
they had given out a loan or something
to someone else or they're receiving a
loan now all of a sudden the other
company might be tied to them or they
had their assets on FTX to some degree
it's kind of scary to think about how
quickly it can all fall
okay so in regards to coinbase like is
is coinbase just as vulnerable now is
there going to be a bank run on on
coinbases influencers start talking
about get your coins off these off these
exchanges right is there going to be
another bank run
and you know how momentum happens right
you've had all the stuff that happened
this summer now you've got FTX who's to
say that all the momentum doesn't cause
another bank run
it does seem like the last since there's
been blood in the water over the last
year I think if you go back the the
all-time high of Bitcoin was almost
exactly a year ago I want to say if you
put in a year it's like 67
000 to 75 down year on year which is
just [ __ ] terrifying absolutely
terrifying and all of the conversations
about nfts have stopped all of the
conversations about decentralized Banks
and that we should adopt it as our
national currency and all of this stuff
all of those conversations have stopped
and you think well when something is an
appreciating asset everybody's happy to
blow it up but when something's a
depreciating asset everybody's terrified
to even touch it
I also think the sentiment turns as well
because crypto for the most part has
been a get rich easy
get rich easy scheme right you see your
neighbor you see your friend who made 1
000 X returns in six months and there's
a there's a certain hopium that comes
with it right if you're not making much
money
if you just find the right coin you will
go from twenty thousand dollar net worth
to two million it's happened enough
there's so many examples of it on social
media that you feel like you're good you
have the ability to be the next one and
I think what happens when the market
tanks the way it has is a lot of people
lose that sentiment and this is where
markets turn especially in something
that is
driven a lot by momentum like crypto is
and uh and so I wonder if the next year
or two you see a lot of turn in in the
market sentiment
what do you think of that being that
being just people's perceptions of of
possibility I actually had a thought
that I want to share with you so one
thing that makes America great is we all
have this ability to of upward Mobility
meaning if we work there's the the ethos
of if you work harder if you start a
business or invest you invest in the
right thing then you will be able to
move up in the social status I think
what happens during downturns and what
we were seeing now the stock markets
crashed real estate's never been this
unaffordable and then you also have the
crypto crash is I wonder if people are
going to start losing that feeling like
they can have upward Mobility right
because if all of that's either stagnant
or crashing 75 that you just alluded to
how do you go from making thirty
thousand dollars a year to a hundred
thousand dollars a year taking on a
bunch of debt that's scary right student
loan debt and that's what I'm really
curious to see over the next 12 months
is if there's a sense if there's a
feeling of that lack of potential upward
mobility within this country so it's a
pool Market means that the cultural
sense of America being the Land of Hope
and blue sky vision
that that might fall away I don't know I
mean you know if you were to read what
most of Twitter and headlines talk about
at the moment I think that seems like
it's long gone to people it that that's
a very cynical view that a lot of people
hold but it's a lot of the people that
seem to be in positions of Social and
media influence that they talk about
America as being this awful terrible
place that needs to be basically torn
down and rebuilt and new I was driving
along from Houston back to Austin with
my housemate about a month ago and we
were going past these two huge uh
flagpoles with these these flags with
the size of a house right and they're
moving super super slowly it's like
really like cinematic and beautiful and
artistic Texas flag and the American
flag and I was looking at it and
thinking that's really [ __ ] cool like
to see that to see the pride in not only
your state but in the country at large
and I said I was like dude did you know
what it is I really enjoy the fact that
I'm here at the moment but I kind of
wish that I'd been here during the 90s I
feel like the 90s was this sort of
absolute golden era where you got out of
the other side of the Cold War no one
really had too many fears about being
nuked 9 11 hadn't happened yet and you
just had this culture
Sports movies cinema Hollywood thing it
was before Michael Jordan Michael yeah
it was basically a country of Michael
Jordan yeah and that to me just seems
like such a golden era and I I'm I don't
know I love being here I think it's a
fantastic country that I very much enjoy
my time in
but it doesn't seem like the same
country that I have read about from the
90s yeah that's a really interesting
idea and it is something I will be
tracking closely
my belief is that right now we're
starting to see the market turn both in
numbers on a screen but also in people's
beliefs
and in their belief that they can make a
lot of money investing
I've noticed there's an energy on
YouTube and You could argue maybe this
isn't the best view of America at whole
I'll totally accept that argument
however I've seen an energy that exists
that I don't think existed 12 to 24
months ago
and I'm worried that a lot of young
people don't think they have the ability
or live within a system that will
provide the opportunity for them to
better their lives and that's what I'm
going to be tracking very closely the
reason why I bring that up is I think
there is a lot of pushback against
influencers right now and I think
there's a lot of I don't like to jump to
the word jealousy I feel like that's a
cliche Trope but I get the sense that
there's a lot of people struggling and
influencers are succeeding and I think
what made this FTX Fiasco so interesting
is that there were very popular
influencers ones that make a lot of
money both the NBA stars Tom Brady and
YouTubers
and they essentially made money
to a large degree you know a significant
amount and then influence people to lose
money and I've never seen the energy
before
that's happening right now right it's
unfortunate circumstance it's un it's
awful it's so it's really sad that
people lost money
I would just be curious to see if like
the same thing happened three years ago
if the same pushback would have happened
I don't know if it's the same then my
theory is wrong but I would I would bet
that the energy is much different today
like the current cultural milieu has
primed itself to be very very negatively
reactive to this that'll be interesting
all right so what do you think give me
your thoughts what do you think about
the influences that have been involved
in promoting FTX
what's so fascinating too about this
recent week with the FTX Fiasco and the
pushback and seeing all the I read the
comments so I see comments and videos
all throughout YouTube
and I think everyone's to blame right if
there's any fraud that goes on if
someone promotes something right if you
go to your neighbor and say hey you
should buy a house it's a great time to
buy real estate the second they buy the
market crashes and their house is worth
a hundred thousand dollars less like
yeah yeah in a sense you should be
blamed a little bit even though it's not
entirely your fault so they'll always be
blamed to give out what I find
interesting is is where they're pointing
the blame and also just the
um just the unfortunate nature that
people were sponsoring something that
was a complete fraud without them
knowing and so the to me the real
question is did people know it was a
fraud or a scam and still promote it
that's where my ethical line is drawn in
the sand why do you think that your
position in coffeezilla's is different
on this we actually agree to a large
extent I think we were just disagreeing
on like some points that aren't really
that relevant for instance here's a
great question so he brought up the idea
of Tom Brady's not a financial expert
Steph Curry is not either so you don't
go to them for financial advice right my
position is they were getting paid let's
just assume 50 million right for Tom
Brady dude to do what he did is probably
I mean he'd have to get paid some
serious dough my guess is he probably
got paid somewhere in the 30 to 50
million range which means he's probably
influencing that much right any business
sense will tell you there they had
reason to believe whatever they paid him
they make back at least one to one and
so
who's really at fault if if Tom Brady's
not a financial expert and people aren't
going to him for financial advice I
totally agree on that point right if you
go to a financial YouTuber there
absolutely is is more responsibility on
them I've never argued that my point is
that Tom Brady influenced at least 100x
to a thousand X the damages and so if
we're being reasonable people here and
let's figure out where to place the
blame my point is that if someone caused
a thousand next person a causes a
thousand X the damages as person b a
reasonable person would place the blame
more on person a they both deserve blame
and that's what I said in my video and
what what I'm bringing up is how
interesting it is to see the feedback
and this is where I get to like the
public sentiment and the negativity is
that I was being incredibly reasonable
even said you can blame my friends they
are partially to blame here this is not
like a new this is not like an argument
I was trying to fight against it's
absolutely true my point is that I
believe there were other factors at this
there were other people that are just to
blame and then coffee Zilla also brought
the point that so and so is not an
expert because this happened right well
if we use that same logic then anyone
who invested in this company is not an
expert I would like to consider
BlackRock Sequoia capital and these
other massive funds as experts I will
not change my position on that because
of FTX nor does anyone nor does anyone
change their opinion so why now are you
changing the opinion of someone who
influenced them does that make sense it
does does it not make sense also to say
that if you push something which
ultimately turns out to be a scam that
your validity and how much Faith people
should have in you goes down a lot
absolutely you should absolutely
question it and now you should wonder
what's next right if if someone were to
promote a scam or a fraud and the next
thing they promote is something similar
I would say major red flags that's not a
good look right I I understand the
approach that you're taking which is
kind of like a utilitarian thing there
is a total pot of damage that has been
done in terms of every influencer that
contributed to FTX we should be
um proportionately putting our Vengeance
and our displeasure toward those that
did the most but when you're referring
to most of the content that's going out
at the moment it's going out on YouTube
it's specifically being aimed at
YouTubers and given the fact that it is
on a platform that these people exist on
Tom Brady doesn't have a YouTube channel
he is not a YouTuber first and foremost
YouTube has every right to point fingers
at members of its own community and say
you've done [ __ ] up we're gonna make
everybody know that this is this is
something that was a huge error on your
part as somebody that claimed to be a
financial expert
I absolutely agree and yeah I never
disagreed with that point at all it's
like if uh if you went on Tom Brady's
website right you're probably going to
see comments about Tom Brady for this
situation you're not going to see
comments about Graham Stefan right so I
totally get that argument my point is
that you can lead because all this comes
down to it's almost all click bait right
like a lot of the venge a lot of
thumbnails is like a little sensational
and you know so-and-so is a scammer
they're the worst person ever right I
get it it's Sensational my point is that
you can make videos about these people
on YouTube 100 that's a smart thing to
do I would do the same thing if I was
talking about something that happened
with YouTubers I'm going to put the
YouTubers in the thumbnail my point is
that throughout the video you then bring
out a reasonable argument that contains
what I'm saying right so you start with
the YouTubers they're at fault however
you then introduce the fact that there
are many other factors in this but I
think if you only target three or four
individuals to me that's dishonest and
that's where I came from and that's why
I responded the way I did when I don't
think something's fair I'm going to
mention it you'd mentioned that you're
friends with a bunch of the guys that
are kind of culpable at the moment I
think you're on the same management
company create a creators agency yeah
code yeah they get a sponsorship deals
is that jading your view of these people
at all is that causing you to be less
unbiased with your approach
do you think we are capable of
understanding our biases
to a degree
you think so yes I think that it's your
job to discount
the
position that you hold based on what you
think your biases would be about those
people so like if someone starts
criticizing my roommate and best friend
I I know that there is going to be a
part of me that is going to immediately
stick up for him no matter what the
criticism is but I need to account for
that it's my job to think I'm close to
this person I have a ton of biases that
are playing with this so if I want to
rationally look at this which is what
you're proposing you're proposing we
take this rational utilitarian view how
much damage is being caused overall that
is absolutely something that needs to be
turned inward on yourself when you're
saying okay
just how biased am I when it comes to me
talking about my friends and and
co-creators within this agency
I agree so number one this is why I
bring up that I'm friends with them
throughout the video so I don't I make
it very clear that you can assess that
however you want right I feel like it
would be disingenuous if I didn't bring
up that point and then I was trying to
play like oh yeah I barely know them
when in fact I do I also by the way I
put my I put creators agency email in my
thumbnail or in my description and I
have all pictures all over my Instagram
it's like it's kind of funny people are
trying to expose this as if it's like
very public so yes I'm so I'm attached
to them but also we're discounting the
fact that I teamed up with them because
I like them in the first place and I
think they're good people who doesn't
dude I eat dinner with these guys every
Tuesday I hang with them for hours you
don't think we discussed this stuff
that's unfortunately what doesn't go
into YouTube videos is you don't see the
hours behind the scenes where I actually
talk to them about FTX and anyway I've
also in regards to bias I think the best
way to challenge a bias is to bring up
an identical scenario but you remove the
emotions meaning let's do the exact same
scenario but it's let's replace the
people where you may have a bias towards
in this case my friends let's replace
them with random people let's call him
Tai Lopez Grant Cardone and all these
people had they promoted FTX here's the
thing I'm very very very confident that
my position would not change obviously
you can believe whatever you want to
believe you don't know me as well as I
know myself the story is Sam Bateman
freed right when I look at stories I
like talking about fraud I like talking
about things that have been proven to me
the story is SBF and how we fooled
everyone and how we fooled some of the
smartest Minds in the world additionally
I would have talked about the
influencers who were at fault for
influencing this
the problem and the reason why I made
the video I did is I would not be making
a sensational title in making the video
only about them the story of Sam bakeman
freed and maybe halfway through the
video I'd bring up Tai Lopez Grant
Cardone Influence People
to
lose money let's in the in the most
simple terms right they influence people
to lose money are they at fault yes but
I would have began the story
with all the people who I believe are
way more at fault and so am I biased of
course it's so funny am I biased of
course I am but also in the same video
coffee solo is the one person like I
respect him more than anyone he's
probably my favorite Creator and I
disagree with him even knowing by
disagreeing with him that I'd cause an
emotional response I could have easily
put clips of his in the video and just
not disagreed and like made the made
people not react the way they did and so
am I biased yes but I also felt like I
was more than fair because I'm defending
friends and I'm actually going against
the one person I respect the most like
we have similar audiences way more than
say like a Graham Stephan or Andre dick
and so I was essentially going against
The Narrative of my own audience and so
when people ask if I'm biased well sure
we all are to some degree but that's
taking away from the fact that I kind of
stuck my neck out knowing that there'd
be a massive negative response
and I still made the video I didn't have
to make the video
so that's my answer I think that one of
the concerns people have one of the
difficult positions that anybody in the
call out space the grift scam
identification space has
people feel like the policeman that
breaks the law is doing something that's
particularly egregious because they're
the ones that are supposed to live by
the law they enact it right and it's
kind of like you guys are the police of
the internet in a way it's like somebody
steps out of line we're gonna find it
we're gonna do a video on it and
everybody's gonna laugh at them and call
them a wanker
that means that you get held to the
highest level of scrutiny of anybody and
it the concern I think is that if you're
supposed to be on the side of holding
people who promote scams accountable
this should be applied in the same
degree of intensity toward everybody
that was a part of FTX
wholeheartedly agree by the way that's
the best argument presented towards me
and one that I actually very much
appreciate when people challenge me like
that because I totally agree the thing
is in my video I say that you can place
blame on them I'm not saying don't place
blame I'm saying everyone is at fault
the argument I present is just to have a
weighted scale so for so we don't argue
in circles here because because I said
weighted scale what I was really trying
to say is you can blame person a and
person B just send a little more of the
Vengeance energy towards person a if he
caused way more damages but yeah I
totally agree man what level of scrutiny
do you think influences should go
through when they do a partnership like
this obviously one of the questions that
we're talking about is how foreseeable
was this in retrospect it seems
completely obvious in advance it seemed
almost completely unobvious
how much
work do you think
these influencers should do to work out
whether or not what they're promoting is
legit
I think step one of this kind of the
first question I think transparency is
always best right if if someone was
emailing them the whole time just saying
I have secret Intel do not promote this
product it is bad and you still do
yeah a little more burden of proof is on
you to show that you're not the bad guy
here so I think it's always important to
come out and just share like what
exactly happened from your perspective I
see nothing wrong if you were duped as
well
I think it's important to talk about it
and not shy away from it
and let people know that you were duped
as well I think what's important is that
you question
you can always question people it's
always fair to be questions that's why
I'm always open to criticism I'm totally
cool with people making videos about me
say whatever you want you can question
my reputation credibility standards of
Ethics yeah whatever totally cool with
everything it's there's I've never had a
problem with people criticizing or
making videos simply questioning and so
in a situation like this
when there is a scenario where you
influence people to lose money I think
you absolutely should have your whole
operation questioned and I think what's
most important is now to see how they
respond right
in a time of Crisis I think how you
respond tells you everything you need to
know if you begin promoting let's say
crypto altcoins or something after this
Fiasco or begin promoting
another crypto exchange probably not a
good look even if it is reasonably safe
and so I think that's um that's where
you question first and then you evaluate
the behavior after if the behavior after
doesn't change
I think you then can attack with the
Vengeance I'm seeing today I think
that's the fairest way to do this well
that's kind of what we were talking
about the beginning right that there is
there is obviously a lot of distaste at
the moment on the internet and the
closest people that can be touched and
that a lot of the internet feels like
they can impact literally the guy that
everybody is trying to find no one knows
where he is on the planet right we don't
know where sandbankment freed is so he's
currently off the table people can send
all of the tweets that they want but
nobody feels like they're actually going
to impact sunbankment free today like
he's already having a pretty bad day
right
the people that most of the internet
that do have discussed at what happened
with the FTX tobacco
the ones that they feel like they can
apply some pressure to
are the creators of the size of a Tom
Nash or a Graham Stefan or whatever and
the reason that they're putting pressure
on them is because they think that they
can make some sort of a change that
they're going to appear within their
mentions that someone's going to send
them the video or whatever
and they know they'll be heard right
that's most important if BlackRock had a
comment section would we see the same
energy I don't know I'm not sure but you
can't access them you can't access Tom
Brady you technically can respond to his
Twitter or something or his Instagram
but he's not going to read it he's not
going to see it yeah so this is the
front line
of the of the pushback and that's why
and look this is what we sign up for I
can't really complain right whenever you
do get pushback it's like we get the
glory we get the the fun life we get the
you know for some of us the money
extreme levels of money and uh and we
get a lot of benefits and then when
something happens yeah I think that was
another coffee criticism it's like you
can't have your cake and eat it too yeah
I totally agree like I'm when you when
you sign up to sponsor something you're
kind of putting your reputation on the
line and I think when something goes
wrong you do take a hit for sure yeah
that's why I would be hesitant to say
um you get like a life you get like a
you're allowed to have one of these
errors within this domain but then if
you do it again then we're gonna come
after you it's like no like [ __ ] 10
billion dollars of money has been lost
like you don't get to you don't get to
get that jet get out of jail free card
it's like it's only a mistake if I make
it twice I I I I don't think that's a
strong argument
my argument that is no just that if that
was what was being put forward I don't
know if that's precisely I think that's
not exactly what you're saying but the
degree of scrutiny that people should go
through about their
the companies that they are partnering
with is that's a really interesting
question like how much due diligence are
you supposed to do presumably BlackRock
did a fair bit of it but then we also
see situations like the SoftBank and
wework one where they also did and
continue to pump tons and tons of money
in so you know that humans have these
biases where a charismatic owner or
someone that's got a great story or
whatever can encourage people to spend
more money than they should do and okay
well just how much time and effort uh
should be spent on this and where's the
threshold right like you say if it was
an obvious [ __ ] coin well what's an
obvious [ __ ] coin like if you've got
selling gravity and promoting like a
fundamental lore of the Universe on one
side and promoting an absolute [ __ ] coin
on the other at what point you are no
longer liable for something going wrong
like if you promoted the US dollar right
which done all right over the last year
if you promoted the US dollar and it
went down like how culpable are you for
that like it's an interesting question
to look at where that line lies and I
think that the internet at the moment
seems to suggest that it lies below
where most of these influences are I.E
that they are culpable for pretty much
everything that's happened
yeah I think that's a fair argument
here's where I come in I like to look at
intentions of behavior in all scenarios
I try to evaluate the best I can I think
that matters most like what are your
real intentions right if your intentions
if you're promoting an altcoin some of
these all coins and it's incredibly
likely that they're going to pump and
dump right and especially those who took
money right before a pump and knowing
there was going to be a dump your
intentions are clearly to take money at
the expense of your audience I think
that's an entirely different argument
than someone who takes money right so
you're both taking money to promote
something but an option two you'd
legitimately think and have reason to
believe that your audience will benefit
from the product or service you're
promoting
in regards to the due diligence that's
such a fascinating argument because we
have an inherent level of trust in
everyone right like you assume BlackRock
did due diligence but now in my point
about like the week the week following
you're going to find all these these red
flags right there was some story about
Sam Bateman and fried in a meeting where
he was trying to raise money he's like
playing video games and and eating
snacks it's like that that is incredibly
a large red flag however there's
probably 100 examples of someone in a
very questionable manner in a in a
fundraising meeting and yet it turns out
to be the most legitimate thing in the
world that's why I'm saying there's
there's like there's not a single in
life there's never like a single thing
that you can point to that goes there's
an obvious fraud or problem
and I can spot it from the start it's
like you can find examples that's why
life is so nuanced
yeah it's challenging what would you do
if you were one of the influencers that
had been involved in this what would you
do moving forward
well first off thankfully I didn't
promote it so thankfully yeah I
purposely stayed away from crypto
anything crypto related man I'm not into
crypto space it helps that my audience
is not crypto related so it it kind of
gave me that easy out right just
anything crypto let's stay away
I think the first thing is you you are
incredibly transparent about the process
you went through to figure out that it's
legit Because by the way I've had
conversations with these guys behind
closed doors that no one knows about
like they've done way more due diligence
than the average person and this is by
the way this also goes into my video
that I make that unfortunately people
just don't see which is you don't think
I've talked to them about this stuff
over dinner
it like they know way more there's my
buddy well Tom Nash is another one he
I'm not gonna explain but he he had a
very trusted source that like let's just
leave it at he had every reason to
believe this was an incredibly
legitimate company way more credibility
his source of way more credibility than
the average audience and so anyway I
think it's important to share all that
you know if you can share how much money
you made and typically it's best to
share the process on how you're going to
improve so you first show empathy
towards the people who lost money you
second share complete transparency about
everything you went through or
even all the benefits you had from it
are you gained and just say this is
really unfortunate and then most
importantly you show that you're willing
to improve
from what happened I think that's the
best case scenario but I've also but
full disclosure I've never experienced
something like that I've never gone
through like a media Scandal and so I'm
I'm just from my perspective that seems
to be the best case like whenever you
see people handle it really well that
seems to be the process they follow yeah
it's an easy uh sideline tactic I think
but when you're in the midst of it
someone's saying I got paid 50 Grand a
month or whatever from FTX meanwhile all
of the people watching are 50 Grand down
you know on their investment I I haven't
seen I don't know whether Tom's done a a
video about this yet I've seen maybe a
couple of the ones online there is a
uh like a a tone to finance YouTube
that's a bit dispassionate
like it doesn't really feel like there's
a massive amount of emotion going in
there it does sometimes feel a little
bit like a press release that's coming
down from a an office on the 45th floor
and I do think that you're right that
you know genuinely showing empathy not
just reading lines that sound like
empathy but genuinely showing empathy is
important I also don't think that I've
seen anybody disclose how much money
they were paid for this partnership yet
so uh I would say that given your
tactics
as of yet no one's followed any of them
yeah I agree yeah that's a really
uncomfortable conversation right is you
got paid for work and you got let's say
let's just call it a fair market rate
and then when that thing goes wrong like
do you give the money back here's the
here's the thing like yes you all in a
perfect scenario you just I got paid
five grand to do this and I'm gonna give
five grand to these homeless puppies
down the street right now oh my God
you're the good guy here but what
happens when it's you know a decent
amount but you did it for so long that
you know you have you're worth something
too you're putting in work and giving
value to the world other than the
sponsorship right and the sponsorships
help you pay your bills and and help you
produce the content that hopefully is
helpful outside of the sponsorship right
yeah what is your responsibility in
making people whole that is an
incredibly tough ethical question and
something that I'm not really going to
speak further on because I don't want to
position my friends as doing the right
or wrong thing because everyone's that's
theirs that's their fight I'm not in
this so you know what would I do
yeah and by the way I think it totally
changes if you get paid a thousand
dollars and you've got a lot of money
you're probably just gonna pay it off
just hey I'll give it up but you know
what happens if my my net worth is X
what happens if I'm getting paid
you know a significant amount from that
sponsorship and now I'm not liquid right
if whatever I got paid if I'm not liquid
that or if it's gonna massively damage
my life you know where's the ethical
line between giving and by the way
what's also challenging about this is
the variable that you can't account for
is that just by giving the money away
let's say that doesn't mean that
everything's made right
you're not you maybe didn't even save
your reputation so that might not even
be the solution right you you might if
you if you gave away the funds you might
help out your your cause in the moment
but is that angry mob that's coming
after you are they gonna be fine with
that and agree that that is an adequate
follow-up to what happened or are they
still going to be just as angry
ultimately that's an incredibly
challenging question ultimately what
people want to see is someone that looks
and sounds and genuinely is sorry about
what's happening what's happened to
everybody like you could give the money
back and do all the rest of it but if
you don't have genuine sympathy and
sorrow for what's going on but on the
other side of this man like I understand
that it's really cool on the internet to
throw shade at these guys and Tom's been
on the show before and I like him I
think he seems like a cool guy from what
however much we've spoken so far and um
I don't know it's like a [ __ ] it's a
hard a hard situation for them as well
like they did we're all dealing with
this together right so they didn't want
this to happen right I understand that
I do think that a lot of the Ayah that's
on the internet at the moment is
Justified
I also think that it's a really [ __ ]
important learning opportunity where you
go right
maybe all crypto stuff should just be
and anybody it should be completely off
out of the the Parview of a good ethical
influencer or Creator and anybody that
does immediately raises a red flag is
like look this person's pushing
something that shouldn't be done
maybe there's a question around given
how many save the kids token nft pump
and dump things
the argument on the other side of that
is have we not already learned this
[ __ ] lesson like how long have people
been [ __ ] about in the decentralized
finance space and there's been rug polls
and there's been all sorts of other
stuff
surely someone should have realized
before now that being involved with this
is putting your audience at huge risk
yeah I totally agree by the way the I
think the most Fair criticism that funny
enough I haven't really seen being
thrown out is that the YouTubers in
question almost all universally follow
sound investing principles which is Max
your 401k get a good job invest in index
funds over the Long Haul invest in real
estate these are all like reasonably
safe and just proven over time and then
to promote crypto
even those their portfolio might have
contained a small amount of crypto so
it's like hey I use this exchange from
five percent of my portfolio's crypto I
do think a lot of the ire and the anger
is coming because they're
their their reputation their brand their
investing strategies has all been one
way and then they promoted
this highly risky asset class and
possibly influence people to engage in
investing strategies that they don't
follow right even though they might say
hey invest only invest five percent of
crypto maybe people put 100 and I think
that's where a lot of the anger comes
from because I would almost guarantee I
haven't been able to prove this that
crypto YouTubers who are probably
promoting FTX and are like the D gen you
know this like cool like DJ and I'm
going all in on Dogecoin if they
promoted FTX I can almost guarantee that
Their audience didn't turn on them
because that's kind of baked into their
brand uh everybody already expected that
they were a piece of [ __ ]
yeah I wouldn't say I wouldn't say piece
of [ __ ] but just like some of these
cultures is just I'm going all in on the
next the next thousand X coin and it's
all kind of part of the gimmick right
it's kind of like here here's an
interesting scenario so if I'm if I'm a
degenerate Gambler and I'm all about
playing slots and I talk about like hey
with 500 a month extra I just go play
Slots and like over time I'll probably
lose by the way this is the best casino
to play at I don't think that's
unethical because your brand is about
playing at casinos however if I being
the guy who's like be safe with your
Investments invest smartly if I all of a
sudden started promoting a casino I
think it would be appropriate for people
to come at me
and you're promoting the same thing the
same service the same product why does
one audience deserve to attack the
Creator why does the other not attack
the Creator I think I think my theory is
that I think this is part of it
yeah I'm not convinced ethically that
that's right but I think in reality
that's how it would happen that people
yeah people just look I'm I'm not
convinced that uh Tom or Graham are
going to take solace in the fact that
they're highly regarded brand position
is the only reason that they're getting
as much Kickback as they are at the
moment I don't think that's going to
make them feel very good uh although it
kind of is like a a backhanded
compliment in a way I also don't think
that it's necessarily going to make the
people that are complaining at them feel
any less virtuous about complaining that
basically situations like this it is
almost impossible to turn down the the
volume it's basically just not going to
happen so if it was me if one of the
guys was like what do I do another
friend of mine true Geordie at the
moment man I don't know whether you've
seen that guy has been [ __ ]
unpersoned from pretty much everything
that was earning him money Jim shark
dropped him my protein dropped him
poker's PokerStars of poker.com dropped
him and then he got banned from twitch
all of those gone completely gone and uh
if I was to give advice to any of those
guys it'd be like
there is no way of speeding this this
situation up put your apology out make
it sincere uh which was criticism that
true Geordie had with his first one he
put this apology out and then at the end
of the video did like a don't forget to
like And subscribe even though it's done
in a semi-jokey fashion I was like oh
dude come on like the Optics are not
good here
um
put your apology out and just wait I I
agree what's what's unfortunate about
media kind of by the way media scandals
is almost like pretentious as if we're
that important this is such like a
two-week thing but anyway
I think when you have scandals and what
makes it so challenging and what makes
someone look like they lack empathy is
that truly the best way to do this
the best way is to move on as if nothing
happened because when you have an angry
mob they're super emotional and no
matter what you do is a loss right so
unfortunately the best case scenario is
just to move forward and I'm not saying
pretend like it didn't happen but you
just move forward and you don't address
it you think
yeah I'm not saying the best as far as
creating the audience or keeping that
relationship with the audience I'm just
saying in in media scandals in almost
all scenarios what do lawyers tell you
don't speak you just move on
you have to let the fire so I think that
from a legal perspective that might be
right when it comes to this new world
though when you have a vacuum of
information it sucks in speculation and
that's speculation that speculation
causes absolute [ __ ] havoc and you
look like an a complete dick if you just
roll forward with the new earnings
report from Apple is out and here's four
reasons why it's whatever like no no no
hang on hang on there's this there's a
huge FTX 10 billion sized elephant in
the room like we need to deal with this
if it was me I would say look just I
think now is not the time to post any
new content get the apology out there
wait for a while for everything to calm
down maybe come back and talk about what
you've learned uh make some statements
about how you're going to change going
forward if you were to say I'm never
going to work with another crypto
exchange again this is a promise I'm
going to make to you this is a lesson
that I've learned this is like look how
have you changed this is what you said
people want to see change in terms of
behavior on the other side of this
I tried to separate those two by the way
I think the best thing to do in almost
all scenarios is just move on like
selfishly because what happens is if you
if you start addressing things you might
bring up another angle and then people
will make videos about that and your
Reef you're rekindling the flame so my
point is that if you just move on like
like let them have their moment they'll
have three days to make all the videos
about you and then they'll have to move
on to something else because they're
just gonna regurgitate themselves but in
within this space I'm saying with
creating a relationship with your
audience what you said is is the best
way so I entirely agree and it's
unfortunate because you have to go
through that pain period of like yo I
messed up or you take a week off for
making videos which is a hurt you know
albeit small but hurt to the income it
hurts the views and all that stuff yeah
I agree
what do you think this means for the
future of crypto it was already
something that people were hugely
skeptical about if they weren't in it it
is yep you you were the one that was
hugely skeptical about it
um
it seems to have been over the last 12
months just a Calamity of errors
faceplant after faceplant after face
plant of
things that would make someone that had
even good faith lose faith and someone
that was skeptical Say Never for me
I feel validated to be honest that's uh
are you smoking at the moment because
yeah people lost money and so when you
feel validated when people lose money
it's like never fun however I was saying
a year ago invest in real estate don't
invest in crypto it's at a bubble please
be careful like there's gonna be a small
subset of you that crush it in crypto
and you guys are awesome but 95 of you
should not be touching crypto and when
it's popping you look like the idiot and
I took a bunch of flames for probably a
month nfts crypto I made a video like
nft markets or the nft bubble is about
to burst right and I made these videos
and people came at me
ugly comments like oh my God Spencer's
an idiot I made so much money well a
year later and I said in the videos I
said in a year I'm gonna have
significantly higher net worth than the
people who are big into crypto and other
than the you know the one percent of
people who figured out and they trade
and they're excellent you know 90 of you
I'm gonna have multiples more net worth
and it came true so that's the
validation part now ego aside I think
it's very unfortunate to see so many
young investors lose money I think a lot
young kids were persuaded very accurate
to this conversation but persuaded
influence into crypto from Tick Tock and
Instagram and I'm I'm the guy on the
side saying like yo these are not this
is not a good investing principles this
is all gambling some of you are going to
win most of you are going to lose
and I really hope that young investors
don't lose sight of like what investing
is because they're taking a punch early
I'm fascinated to see how long the
market lasts this bear Market because I
think crypto is going to be wiped out
for three years and I think what is
going to also happen is that get rich
easy mindset is gone and so all these
people that were coming in and gambling
all that liquidity is gone our
institutional investors gonna pour money
in now I don't know maybe they do and
that that will combat my argument
however if a lot of retail money it no
longer enters
how is crypto going to survive all coins
how do they survive yes but
I don't think that you can
underestimate the power of somebody
believing that they can get rich off of
absolutely nothing very fair right Mike
winitz uh intro to his old entrepreneur
thing was the people that got the
richest during the gold rush in the
1800s weren't the people that weren't
searching for Golds they were the people
that sold the shovels
as long as there is an incentive for
someone to tell you that you can get
rich they will find a cognitive bias or
a new neuro-linguistic programming way
of writing the correct piece of website
copy or getting the correct influencer
at the right time with the right script
to put the right video out and the
number of people that are going to
continue to fall for that because this
one's different
I think that there are unlimited lives
on that there is a unlimited number of
times that that same formula can be used
is it going to have to look different
yes but there's a a literally infinite
number of ways that you can combine
words on a page so and how powerful is
that too by the way so like yes I agree
you know that will be influential and
there will always be people that sign up
for a course on how to get rich in in
six months how many people fall for that
is always the question right because if
a lot of people do then yeah there's
going to be liquidity and every little
uh dog puinu zombie Eno and stuff it's
just gonna pop up right but once all
that money leaves unsolve that little
gambling money leaves
I don't know oh so what you're saying is
that because there's going to be less
Capital to support these projects there
is going to be less places for people to
waste their money
yes exactly exactly because a lot of
these projects succeeded because the the
velocity from the start was so powerful
right they get a bunch of people in a
Discord you'd have a thousand people
sign in and there was no liquidity so if
you put it at ten zeros one I don't know
what number that is right so if a
thousand dollars enters into the coin it
all of a sudden the market caps a
million dollars or whatever you get a
Discord full of a thousand five thousand
ten thousand people from Twitter and
Instagram and all this and and marketing
shout outs and then all these people put
money into the system it within that the
first 24 hours the coin spikes and then
all of a sudden it attracts more well
what happens when all of those discords
don't exist
what happens if there's only a couple
and the money's really not that good and
the early spike is not that great and
people don't make money and then they're
like I'm not going to be in the next
project think about it like this think
about it like
um each
five to ten year uh miniature generation
that is thinking about investing
needs to learn a lesson of pain in order
to ensure that someone that has the
predisposition to a get rich quick
scheme gets burned so that they don't
lose tons of money treat it like an
inoculation right like this is a small
loss and for some people it's going to
be entire life savings right that they
had absolutely everything in FTX and
that's now gone and it's gated and they
can't get it out like awful for those
people for a bunch of other people it's
going to be smaller amounts right large
portions perhaps of the net worth but an
amount which is recoverable as far as
they can they they will move forward and
that means that in future they're going
to look at investing in a different way
I because I think that the fundamental
desire to get rich easy is never going
to change amongst humans and the
incentive for the people that want to
capitalize on those people
is never going to change
I think that you're going to just
continue to end up with this same
repeating cycle every 10 years or every
five years over and over and it's just
going to be an inoculation each time and
it's going to be a new cohort of people
that come in and every time that it
happens they go who could have seen this
coming if you'd spoken to somebody that
was 10 years older than you maybe they
could have told you about the
dot-com bubble or the housing market
bubble or the crypto but or whatever it
is like pick whatever the thing is that
you want to get your painful lesson from
and I think that consistently that
that's the only way that this can happen
and there are people that have a
disposition like mine like
I have played about with small amounts
of money percent single digit percent of
my net worth and the rest is in real
estate and in the s p and that's it
right like and I've spoken to I don't
know much about Finance but I've spoken
to Morgan hausel a [ __ ] ton and I
spoke to the guys that did uh uh just
keep buying who was that
um
just in somebody somebody anyway wrote a
great book uh my point being
minimum viable strategy when it comes to
looking at investment
there are a ton of people out there that
will do that the number of people that
are always going to be susceptible to
the other type of investment I don't
think is going to change
that's very fair I think you're I think
you're absolutely right and it's why
we've seen so many iterations of the
fake gurus in like six years
right you had first off the fake group
of courses then you had these Automation
Services YouTube automation then you've
got crypto and nfts what's next
that is true you have been able to call
them out so one of the interesting
dynamics that I've seen is uh dokwon
Martin shkreli bit boy a bunch of other
people every previous
generation of villain has celebrated the
uh now more in Vogue foe of SBF being
the current villain that everybody wants
to have a crack at like that's been so
in it's like uh Martin shkreli did a a
podcast a couple of days ago saying to
do like dokworm is on there with him and
skreli's saying uh Jail's not that bad
are you like
wow it's just it's so [ __ ]
fascinating to see this uh like [ __ ]
Suicide Squad of you want to know why
this stuff exists
what punishment did Martin shkreli
really have and let me ask you an
ethical question one that's really tough
if you're 24 years old and you're smart
enough to understand that you can make
10 million dollars in 24 months and the
risk is reputational harm you get
slandered in the media and you go to
jail for two years but you come out and
you have all your little Investments
you're smart enough to put your money
elsewhere so like people can't come
after it so when you get out of jail you
got it I'm not saying I'd do it I would
never do that however there's enough
people in this world that care more
about money and they'll make money at
the expense of others risk jail time and
in some cases serve jail time but they
know the way our system works is in two
or three years when you're out you now
have the you know how this like big
Persona which Jordan Belfor has now been
able to turn if you go through the
Redemption Arc you now have the you have
massive audience already and then if you
just go through the Redemption Arc you
can actually capture like 80 of those
people so anyway but then you come out
and have a bunch of money there's this
guy named bam-man Kevo that I've gone
after and this guy like stole who knows
how much millions and millions of
dollars he scammed them from credit card
fracking I think is the word they use he
goes to jail and comes out and buys
Lamborghinis and so these guys what a
lot of people have figured out is that
you commit all this fraud white collar
crime of course you serve two or three
years in jail at worst and it's not in
County Prison and then you come out and
you've got massive amounts of money
stored away and then you just live the
rest of your life however you want I
hate I hate it because I think that's
ethically bankrupt that's awful so
enough people are going to do this what
I'm getting at is I if we lived in a
system where these people were their
lives were ended the second they were
convicted of this
how many times would we see this happen
my guess is it would reduce probably 90
but what you're looking for with the
justice system is not Vengeance right
you're looking for Justice right right
people that have lost all of their money
they might want to see this person
behind I'm pretty sure that I saw uh SPF
should get the death sentence was
trending on Twitter earlier on yeah so
I'm going to the extreme I don't I don't
know my opinion on that but like I'm
going to the extreme to prove a point
like for instance if you if you drove
after drinking one beer and you got
caught in the punishment is that you no
longer have a YouTube channel you can no
longer put out content online and you
will serve 10 years in jail and you are
unable to have a woman visitor to uh you
know have fun as a guy would you would
you drink a beer and drive I'd like to
think that you would you would even
after a beer you would strongly consider
asking for a ride or taking an Uber
right now I feel like the punishment for
all these crimes is so minimal that the
only thing we have is Media the only
thing we have is like how can we at
least somewhat try and prevent this
which is funny because that actually
counters the entire argument which is
like then what happens when the
influencers influence you to be a part
of the scheme right but uh anyway we
live in a system where I'm going through
a lawsuit right now and like the amount
of money you spend on legal fees for
something so minimal is just it's so
insane that we live in a clown World in
a lot of ways and it's very unfortunate
and I think that's why a lot of these
schemes happen one of the interesting
things you've got is how much somebody
values money and how much somebody
values perhaps their freedom all their
time or their reputation or whatever it
is so
a problem you encounter is when you have
somebody
who doesn't value their freedom or their
time very much but values money
massively because for that person going
to jail for five years for 10 years for
10 mil would make complete sense whereas
you know if you'd say would you go to
jail for 10 years to get 10 million or
one million dollars there would be a
huge bunch of people that would say no
and what you have are differing levels
of priorities and what you need is like
a [ __ ] bespoke judicial system that
works out how much pain a person is
going to pay individually for that
particular type of Freedom that's being
taken away from them and yeah I think
that you're right there are people out
there for whom material wealth is so
high up on their list of priorities that
they would be prepared to pay pretty
much any price in order to get 10
million bucks uh and for those people
yeah you know two years in jail and an
ankle tax
yeah it's a fair trip yeah that's why a
lot of fake news Exist by the way is
because they value your thousand dollars
for their course over customer
satisfaction the the stuff that a lot of
the the real bad fit gurus do it's very
clear that they very much value the
small amount of money they make per
customer the thousand bucks or whatever
they don't care about their reputation
they don't care about screwing the
person they'll take the money and
they'll never give a refund that's how
they're able to make their money
how do you stop it you can't another
interesting element of all of this is
the effective altruism movement so this
is a charity a very Advanced charity
that looks to try and maximize the
effectiveness of any money which is
donated to it uh a lot of people have
heard online about the bloat and the
sort of uselessness of many Charities
out there that it's basically being
spent on expenses and a bunch of other
things and it's just a marketing
campaign that allows Executives to live
a nice life and doesn't really make much
real world impact effective altruism is
a part of long-termism which was started
by Will mccaskill who's been on the show
Will's having a super super bad time of
it at the moment because sandbankment
freed was the single largest donor to
that his plan was to donate almost all
of the wealth that he generated he was
planning to earn to give which is make
as much money as is possible and give it
all away to the most effective charities
the really [ __ ] interesting question
that needs to be asked is from a
utilitarian perspective is it ethical to
con people out of money in order to give
that money to causes which are more
worthy or would make better use of the
money
than the people that originally had it
and donated it like it do the ends
justify the means is a [ __ ] for me
and remembering that the EA movement is
all about utilitarianism rationalist
perspective all that stuff
that's a really [ __ ] difficult
question to answer
are humans even capable of answering
this one that's like so challenging
right I think my mind immediately goes
to if there's if there's victims in
anything you try to avoid it at all
costs right so my my mind goes there so
okay you just explained there is a
victim you take one dollar from person a
you give two dollars a person B and
somehow they're able to create a system
where everyone benefits more maybe at
the expense of one but five people are
benefited it's you know what's a really
fascinating thought exercise for this is
the it's the why train where like if if
the train goes down One path it it
probably takes away one person
or whatever you know the other one's
like five people but it saves a kid or
something yeah it's like a moral dilemma
that's so incredibly difficult to answer
that's so fascinating man because then I
think the counter argument people can
bring up is that's just how our system
works it's like in almost all scenarios
you're you're taking from someone and
giving to others dude I have a friend
capitalism to a T I have a friend who
believes that everybody is someone's
exit liquidity
everyone is someone's exit liquidity
that's how he sees Humanity
I'm someone's exit liquidity and so are
you and so is he and so is the person
that's watching yeah we buy real estate
right we're the exit liquidity from the
previous owner there everyone is someone
made a bunch of money I mean my my
intuition like obviously it's nice for
me to put forward this sort of like
semi-autistic argument about like oh
well what happens if you can make do as
much good with the money and stuff like
that it's like no you don't get to take
people's [ __ ] money like no matter
what it is that you're doing it is that
person's money that's what property
rights are so no you don't get to do
that also even if you just take a
[ __ ] utilitarian approach to it loss
of version suggests that we get far
greater pain from losing than uh
pleasure from Gaining uh I'm not sure
that if you take it to the absolute
extreme of people dying and starving in
Africa there has to be a point in which
that balances out but no you don't get
to take people's [ __ ] money for this
stuff however the effective altruism
community at the moment which people
kind of always had a bit of a an ax to
grind against because it was
a lot of smart people that had these
long word ideas and this philosophy that
was a little bit difficult to get a hold
of and it was a little bit of a gated
community it was kind of you couldn't it
wasn't super accessible for most people
and um
there has been a lot of Brewing
resentment I think and this situation
has given a vector of attack to all of
those people and it's not just EA that's
Comfort right it's been uh polyamory so
because a lot of the people in EA are
non-monogamous as well because it's
forward-thinking San Francisco type
people uh and what else came for it as
well like utilitarianism rationalism
like all of these different things any
opportunity and this is how you know
that I think it's
the problems with EA didn't exist within
it the problems are it's just an
opportunity for someone to really really
Point their Ayah at that thing because
there's now a Justified
um weakness in it
how about this you also have Sam Bateman
freed could argue in his mind you
probably did that money in my hands is
better suited than money in other
people's hands and this is where it gets
dangerous right because then someone
who's evil it just goes oh I can handle
the money better and they take all the
money and then you go oh wait a second
one person was better off and 10 million
people were worse off wait a second how
do we allow this happen well in his mind
he probably justifies his behavior as I
could do better with the money
it's where it gets dangerous what was
that Kanye West lyric about allowing one
man to have all that power
that's the issue another interesting
comparison would be between crypto
exchanges now and banks in pre-1930s
before the FDIC was created in order to
protect people's money that's [ __ ]
interesting and backgrounds are
dangerous in any system man dude I think
moving forward
it would be super super surprising if we
don't see this being used by the
government as an opportunity to increase
scrutiny you know bringing it full
circle back to the is SPF actually
secretly a part of the government trying
to bring down crypto from the inside
whether he is or isn't the outcome on
the other side of this has to be
increased scrutiny there is so much ah I
was going to say there is so much
attention being paid to this but there's
only attention being paid to this on
Twitter and on YouTube and on Reddit
mainstream media New York Times hasn't
had a single article about this
oh wow
interesting have you seen a single
article from The New York Times about
this at all let me see I'm going to
bring this up
it might have taken a couple days I
don't know
New York Times what happened to FTX
here's what here's what to know
embattled crypto exchange files for
bankruptcy FTX investigating possible
hack who bet oh so this one's come out
today who Bears the blame for ftx's
failure uh
[ __ ] Interesting Man by the way I'd
be really interested to uh read that
article and see if they even bring up
YouTube influencers
I mean think I think that's a pretty
good argument for me right if the news
article doesn't even bring up their name
but that's only if you presumed that the
news article is the Arbiter of
everything that is just an appropriate
in the world like I think the New York
Times investigative skills have been
called into question and their their
biases have also been called but yeah my
whole argument is just like yo there's
people way bigger than this that are way
more to blame that's kind of my point
it's like all the all the media
attention is probably going to go to the
big players and if they don't even bring
up the crypto influencers here's another
thing is like the
FTX has you know billions in assets you
know I would love to find out who
influenced like if there's any way to
find out who influenced the most right I
mean that's not fun because then you're
going to look at someone and go like you
influenced the most losses but like
theoretically if you could just clap
your hands and have data to anything you
want in this world if you're like give
me you know people's minds and who
influenced like who got someone to open
up their their phone and download the
app was it watching Tom Brady was it
some ad on TV was it just some generic
ad of FTX and like okay my buddy said
something who influenced the most and I
would love to know and unfortunately we
won't know I would love to know if we
had that number would people react to my
video the same right if you found out
that we you brought Tom Nash like our
buddy Tom Nash if he influenced
literally zero dollars but he's getting
all of this pushback like if his
customers literally lost zero dollars
but yet he's getting all this pushback
is that fair right because if there were
no damages where's the where's the
problem is there not something is there
not a problem if somebody try eyes to
promote an unethical product and the
only reason that nobody loses money is
because of a failure of conversion
oh yeah yeah well again it goes back to
like did you know right if you were
knowingly promoted like some really
really really bad product with you know
terrible customer reviews then yeah
you're at fault no matter what whether
people sign up or not that just makes
you a scumbag I also did it no the way
that the New York Times is going to do
this with you saying about how um if the
New York Times brings up the YouTube
influences then maybe that gives a
little bit more legitimacy to the fact
that they they were a little bit
culpable for this
the New York Times will hopefully look
at the Tom Brady's the Stephen Currys of
the world right but if they just look at
the big players who would hold
accountable the small players it's like
New York Times is the domain of normal
media like it's what our parents read
right
YouTube is what we watch you have
partitioned off the Battlegrounds and
the accountability into the appropriate
audiences uh as is supposed to be done
and I think that that was the argument
that we came back to earlier on right
that you know this happened on YouTube
therefore it's held accountable on
YouTube on YouTube You've Got YouTubers
at YouTube go or on YouTube go YouTubers
100 as you should you shouldn't put Tom
Brady in the title you should put people
who are on YouTube I get it it's the
game
but it would also be a little
disingenuous by the way to be fair
for the New York Times to not at least
consider all the people that promoted it
on social media social media is so much
a part of it so that would actually be
I'd argue against my own position that
it is it is not good journalism on their
part to not at least consider maybe you
did I don't know did FTX come from
YouTube or Instagram like were people
looking at for it so let me look it up
and if they looked up FTX now they'd be
able to very quickly find out that
there's drama and they'd be able to
figure that out so that would be that'd
actually be a fascinating argument
against my own position that maybe both
sides are doing you want conversion you
want conversion tracking across across
everything and then you can just
distribute hate appropriately
yeah it kind of sucks when your brain
works the way mine does where it's I
don't I don't I don't relate to outrage
I don't experience that when when
something big happens I don't turn to
emotions I immediately start looking for
all solutions or all like let me break
down like what actually happened
especially nowadays in the media you
never know the real story and so
whenever something happens I go okay let
me sit back and assess everything let me
look into every little detail I don't
have this like outrage
uh response that I feel like a lot of
people do at least in the comments
section they do
welcome to YouTube man look Spencer
Cornelia ladies and gentlemen uh if
people want to check out more of the
stuff that you do where should they go
YouTube Spencer Cornelia I hope you like
my videos if you do great join the crowd
if you don't that's cool too join that
crowd
spend there's a crowd for both I
appreciate you thanks man what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace